cuz we're gonna be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this was the last Monday morning in her
life
you
[Music]
long week a lot of grinding that's good
easy another Nate this hominid this is
what I've been trying to tell you and
then I layer on the fact that I wasn't
born in America so first of all was
impossible then I end up in [ __ ]
Soviet Union right and then after 80
years 60 years 77 you know 65 years of
like Cold War hardcore communism there's
a moment in time that allows me to leave
Soviet Russia come to America like like
Victoria yeah what uh how long you been
working out together six months so what
are the biggest changes the exchange is
your performance yeah things that things
will bring value to other people who are
looking out okay we're like recording
Lotus in the incense what's happening I
think number one is we realized what was
going on
mobility wise like structure wise so we
got after your hip yeah you know sitting
a lot if you're spent a lot of time
sitting you aren't doing soft tissue
work for your hip got to make sure
that's being taken care of stretching
your gluts also helped a lot right
watching the glute stretching the glutes
do a flip stretch your glutes
[ __ ] you're sitting down a lot
you gotta stretch your glutes
thank you stretching your calves is also
another big one especially if you travel
a lot if you sit down a lot your calves
are going to be tight a lot of time so
stretching your calves calves are a hell
[ __ ] the calves having a pretty
reflective morning and day just things
are good life is good you know
yesterday's episode with with a
Nate getting blown away by the 440
trillion to one of becoming human guys
one in kiss one in four hundred trillion
one in four hundred trillion that's
crazy this is what I've been try to see
Amy it is ridiculously hard to become a
human being and then these [ __ ]
complain it's your one the greatest
lotto and then by the way let's get real
a little more serious we live in America
right I mean there's a bunch of white
dudes in here and thank you for holding
it down but like like there's that like
people are not people are not
quantifying their luck and they complain
about dumb [ __ ] that's right
yeah that's all oh yeah yeah like that
that's my thing the whole tree like the
Monday morning you could have been a bus
like I believe that like not that I'm
I'm not confused I know bus is not alive
but a tree is that step and an app you
know a dog is standing no sense right
cuz it's rigged Nate literally back to
your dad literally your dad could have
gotten up real quick and got another
glass of water and that would have
changed the whole sequence of events and
you would not exist
your dad isn't completely hydrated and
has enormous amounts of sperm even
though that's how I think about life and
my ethos it was a good reminder for me
to write like I just wish people could
understand I just wish people could
understand we're so fortunate
everything in life is how you look at it
how do I help you guys go deep into
yourself whether that is going and
seeing psychiatrist you know a therapist
somebody that can help you whether
that's to have the one conversation that
unlocks your whole life with your mother
like how do I help you get to that place
of peace that allows you and gives you
the power to look at life to look at
life the way I and the other people that
I know that are happy to do which is you
know it's good this bad thing happened
now I'm gonna make it good this good
thing happened I'm so thankful just a
whole neck of all that is good
it's just good on the sleep engaged all
day with the fans
nothing too miraculous but a lot of you
engage with me today
[Music]